today on the Matt Walsh show don't be
fooled by the reopening that's happening
in many states across the country it's
not a real reopening and I'll explain
what's actually going on and five
headlines including Stacey Abrams
defending an accused rapist because
she's desperate for the vice president
job and a bishop claiming that God
doesn't punish those are direct quotes
and in our daily cancellation I will
deliver perhaps the most well deserved
cancellation yet so we get to all of
that and but first i I just factor off
the table I just want to mention this
cuz I just read it I guess I could save
it for the headlines but I would I
mention it now there's this story out of
Kentucky governor Andy Beshear
he gave a gave a press conference a few
days ago he was talking about the
unemployment issue in the state and he
was saying that there are people who are
filing false unemployment claims and
either as a joke or because they're scam
others so or whatever and he was
admonishing the people following up
filing the false claims and he mentioned
specifically one case of a false claim
he said that somebody filed a false
claim in the name of tupac shakur and he
said that's very bad don't do that and
he went on about it
well cut it it turns out that there
there is actually a Tupac Shakur living
in Kentucky and he's unemployed right
now he was really filing for
unemployment benefits now this is not
the Tupac Shakur the rapper from the 90s
of course we know he is still alive but
he's in he's in Cuba with Elvis he
certainly wouldn't be hiding out in
Kentucky you'd be a little bit
conspicuous there probably so he in so
Tupac Shakur of Kentucky contacted the
governor somehow and said hey man what's
going on I'm real okay and I'm
unemployed he just accused me of
something and so Beshear had to come out
and apologize to Tupac Shakur for
accusing him of not being real and
that's what that's that's an actual
thing I have the thing is when you hear
this your first thought is that you feel
sorry for Tupac Shakur because I mean
first the guy was named Tupac Shakur do
you think his parents named him Tupac
Shakur that's bad enough
and then he's unemployed and and now
he's being accused of being a scam
artists in front of in front of in front
of the entire state so you think you
know you feel bad for him
then you read the story and you find out
I mean you still feel bad for him for
being unemployed but it turns out that
he changed his own name legally in 1998
to to Pok Shakur and that makes I don't
mean to victim blame that does make me
think it's a little bit your fault I
think if you change your name to Tupac
Shakur that there's going to be
confusion and probably or throughout the
last 22 years of your life there's been
a lot of confusion I imagine so you
can't really blame Bashir that much now
if you if you if you take on a name like
that there's some stuff's gonna come
with the territory you just have to
accept it it would be like if I change
my name to I don't know Britney Spears
or something legally and then I got
annoyed every time people were confused
by it I go in for a job interview and
someone says says here that your name is
Britney Spears yeah what's the issue
what's the problem why is everyone
always look like that when I say what a
guy can't be named Britney Spears so I
can kind of see I could see from
Bashir's perspective but anyway great
great stuff great for everyone except
for those directly involved all right
let's move to this where we're told the
story we're told is that the country is
reopening slowly states are reopening
across the country but a word of caution
about that when you hear about the
reopening of the states you have to
actually look at the plan that many of
these states have enacted and if you do
you notice two things first that the
plans are laid out in an arbitrary way
and that's been the that's been the case
that's been the theme all along these
arbitrary regulations the art the
regulations were arbitrary to begin with
and so of course now they're being
repealed and put aside in an arbitrary
way and to you you see that in so many
cases the states that are quote-unquote
reopening aren't really reopening at all
and that's a very important point I'll
get more into this in detail in just a
second but first a word from our friends
at noon you know you hear about one size
fits all you go to the store is a one
size fits all clothing
about one-size-fits-all is that it never
fits all that's especially the case for
me one size fits all anything doesn't
fit me because I have a very weirdly
shaped frame I'm just very apparently
there's there's no one quite as
misshapen as me so I can never fit into
the one size fits all stuff well with
all the diet and exercise noise out
there how do you know what's gonna work
with you with that when it comes to
diets especially and exercise routines
it cannot be one size fits all you have
to decide what your goals are and Noom
is there to help you reach them this is
not a one-size-fits-all approach Noom
knows that strong community and expert
coaching are key to making lifestyle
changes at last
whether trying to lose weight or get or
get or get fit whatever your goals are
new MS there to help you and I know that
that's been my experience with Neumann
that's what I really appreciate about it
is that it is so specific to what your
own particular goals are you don't all
have to have the same goals and you'll
have to go about it the same way NUMA
just to your lifestyle it helps you to
understand the psychology behind better
decision making to make you smarter and
then it puts you in charge with
moderation / restriction no food is good
or bad or off limits it's all about
moderating and having a good plan in
place so shut off all the noise and sign
up for your trial today at noon calm n
oom calm / Walsh get personalized
guidance at noon calm / Walsh that's n
oom calm / Walsh so let's look at an
example of a state that's supposedly
reopened in California
here are the stages of reopen and
reading this from ABC 7 in California
says stage 1 everyone is either staying
at home or a member of the essential
workforce this is a stage where it now
and will stay in until modification to
the statewide state home order is made
stage 2 and this is weeks away we're
told reopening lower-risk workplaces
including non-essential manufacturing
schools childcare facilities
retail businesses for curbside pickup
only offices we're working remotely
isn't possible but can be modified to
make the environment safer for employees
and in stage 3 this is months away
reopening higher risk
places which require close proximity to
other people including hair salons nail
salons gyms movie theaters sporting
events in-person religious services
churches and weddings and end stage 4 is
ending the state home order altogether
so in California even to begin the
reopening phase is weeks away and then
when they do begin in large sectors of
the economy will remain closed for
months and churches will have to remain
closed for months - if you want to get
married in California you are out of
luck for the near future you can't do it
schools can go back but churches cannot
then let's look at Maryland reading from
the Baltimore Sun it says in the first
stage local governments would have the
flexibility to make decisions on
reopening libraries parks and other
services Stage two would allow for
larger social gatherings indoor gym
classes regular childcare increased mass
transit schedules indoor religious
services restaurant bar service with
restrictions and elective procedures at
hospitals Stage three would allow large
social gatherings the reopening of
entertainment venues large religious
gatherings and fewer restrictions on
visitors at nursing homes and hospitals
now Hogan says it's optimistic to think
that maybe the first stage might start
as early as May so again we're well if
you want to talk about a full reopening
of the economy of Maryland we are
it sounds like months away from that
Pennsylvania they have a fun color-coded
three three phase system of reopening
right now we're in the red phase that
means everyone has to stop doing
everything can't do anything okay we
know about that and then we move on to
the yellow phase which according to trib
live.com you telework must continue
where feasible businesses with in-person
operations must follow safety orders
childcare facilities open with worker
and building safety orders restrictions
in place for prison and congregate care
schools closed for in-person instruction
state home restrictions lifted in favor
of aggressive mitigation gatherings of
more than 25 prohibited so presumably
that includes churches recreation and
health and wellness facilities such as
gyms and spas and all entertainment
venues including casinos and theatres
remain closed bars at
ron's limited to carry out and delivery
only and then the green phase is
everything is opening North North
Carolina there in a full lockdown mode
until at least may 8th may extend that
longer and then reading from the
Charlotte Observer the lock downs when
they when they do begin and they might
begin May 8th if they do when they do
phase 1 reopened parks allow for
non-essential travel to retailer sites
like clothing and sporting goods stores
books and housewares shops those
businesses must implement social
distancing cleaning protocols and screen
employees for symptoms gatherings of
more than 10 people are banned people
are encouraged to our face coverings at
least two or three weeks later phase 2
will begin by lifting the state home
order but encouraging at-risk groups to
remain home limited capacity for
restaurants and stuff and then phase 3
which is a full reopening that's four to
six weeks after phase two
okay and in fact even a place like Texas
the lock downs are being eased but
restaurants can only have to limit their
dining capacity to 25 percent so you see
what we're hearing about what the lock
downs being lifted is BS it's not true
most states are planning to keep a
relative stranglehold on the economy for
many more weeks if not months that's the
reality and what is the point of this
what is it achieve why open in in these
phases rather than all at once here's
the reality that we have to face
eventually because this this three phase
or four phase or seven phase whatever
PHA however many phases it is in in
whatever state this strategy seems to be
accepted by most people as as logical
but I don't think it is I don't see the
point of it the reality is it we are
going to be opening the economy fully
eventually with the virus still out
there there is no way around that you
can have all the phases you want one way
or another
we are going to have to get back to life
to relatively normal life with the virus
still out there that is going to happen
everyone needs to get that through their
heads it is going to happen so then what
is the point of stalling or staggering
it like this what really is the
difference between Pennsylvania opening
completely now or in August I mean one
difference is that in August the economy
is going to be even in in even more
shambles than it is now but whether we
open now or in August the virus will
still exist there will still be no
vaccine so why stall until then you
could say all you want out we're
flattening the curve we're flattening
the curve okay so what eventually you're
gonna have to open again and then
there's gonna be another curve if the
virus still exists one thing I've heard
is that we don't want to throw open the
doors and let people get back to the
lives because we can't trust people to
be responsible so we have to ease them
into it that's nonsense
again we're going to have to trust
people eventually I either we do it
later and we continue to destroy the
economy in the mean time or we do it now
that's your choice those are the only
choices either people will go back to
their lives while remaining smart and
vigilant and and practicing good hygiene
and so on or they won't but but putting
it off longer isn't going to change that
result so if you're worried that people
won't be smart about it and they're
gonna you know do stupid things or
whatever that's no matter we could okay
open now we can open in July August
September October that's still going to
be the issue we really have two choices
here okay there are only two ways to go
we can trust people citizens to be
responsible with their freedom or we can
trust government to take the freedom
away and be responsible with the power
that they get in the process those are
your two options there cannot be a third
you trust the pea
with their freedom or the government
with power those are got which is it
which do you trust more which leap of
faith is more dangerous which downside
are you more willing to deal with trust
the citizen with freedom or the
politician with power now I think it
goes almost without saying that the
former trusting the trusting freedom
over power is the more American choice
but you have to choose either way and
luckily we don't really have to
speculate how these things go we've seen
what the government does with this power
and it's not pretty
it is indeed exactly what you would
expect them to do abuse it wield it in
egregious and gratuitous waves take the
power we give them use it as a cudgel
against us grab even more power that's
what they do
that's what they've done we've seen it
now have we had enough or do we want
more sure on the other side we've seen
examples of people being stupid some
people in Chicago had a party a house
party over the weekend with a stripper
and everything and you know people
packed in very tightly into it into a
house dozens of people maybe even more
than that that obviously is a stupid
thing to do right now okay and there are
people doing stuff like that are they in
the majority are most people doing that
sort of stuff no and besides they did
that even though it's illegal that's the
point
so the lockdown order did nothing to
stop anyone from actually congregating
and having a party if they want to have
a party
so the reckless and irresponsible people
are going to be reckless and
irresponsible
regardless only the responsible people
can be controlled potentially by
regulations and laws and that sort of
thing and they're exactly the ones you
don't need to control in this situation
because they're going to be responsible
so the whole thing doesn't make sense
the whole strategy to me is is
nonsensical and my fear is that people
will be satisfied and satiated because
we here though we're in the process of
reopening know where we are really not
the game here is to keep us closed down
while pretending that we're opening up
so the powers that be they want to have
it both ways but let's not let them do
that okay we're gonna go to headlines in
a second but first I want to check in
with wise foods our sponsor wise company
recently changed their name to ready
wise and now is a better time than any
to be prepared with long term
nutritional food options I mean this you
couldn't ask for a more timely thing to
consider here
ready wise has many options like
emergency meals freeze dried fruits and
vegetables for convenient on-the-go
nutrition new adventure meals for hiking
camping other outdoor activities ready
wise meals are easy prepare all you had
to do is add water could be even I
couldn't screw that up and they have a
very long shelf life you know this is
this is as I said a perfect time to be
prepared for a long-lasting futons
especially when they're talking about
disruptions in the supply chain
disruptions to the especially when it
comes to things like meat and so on
scarcities and and everything else now's
the time to be prepared ready wise makes
being prepared simple and affordable you
order online have nutritious meals
shipped directly to your doorstep can't
get easier than that
ready wise uses the finest ingredients
the latest food preparation technology
all to ensure optimal taste and
freshness because just because you're
being prepared and you're getting this
food doesn't mean that it has to taste
bad ok don't don't settle for that
ready wise makes delicious food as well
this week my listeners can get free
shipping at ready wise calm when
entering Walsh at checkout or by calling
eight five five four seven five three oh
eight nine
ready Wise has a 90 day no question
asked return policy so there's no risk
taking the initiative to get yourself
and your family prepared today that's
ready wise ready wise calm ar e ad y wi
SE comm promo code Walsh to get free
shipping all right Stacey Abrams is a
woman devoid of any political talent
charisma skill let alone achievement
there's just nothing about her that is
for a political perspective at all
exciting or engaging but she desperately
wants to be vice president and she has
been on TV essentially threatening Biden
to get the job saying that he needs to
hire a black woman and hey she just so
happens to be a black woman you know she
what she's saying is hey I'm not saying
hire me but I am saying that if you
don't hire a black woman you're racist
and by the way I'm a black woman hint
hint nudge nudge in fact being a black
woman appears to be her only
qualification for the job which is why
she leans so heavily on it well she
seems to have switched her tactic a
little bit here because she's gone from
threatening Biden to sucking up to him
to try to get the job she was asked
about the rape allegations against the
Democratic nominee and here's what she
said brave courageous Stacey Abrams says
I believe women deserve to be heard and
I believe that has happened here she's
she sang Tara Reid has been heard the
mainstream media has ignored it but
she's been heard
the allegations have been heard and
looked into by who who's looked into
them wait nobody in the mass media has
and four too many women often that is
not the case
the New York Times conducted a thorough
investigation and nothing in The Times
review or any other later reports
suggest anything other than what I
already know about Joe Biden that he
will make women proud as the next
president of the United States this
woman is such a snake she really is I
just have such contempt for all of these
people who have been going on with the
with the me to believe all women stick
for years now and and they're throwing
all that to the side because we keep
comparing I've compared Biden and
Kavanagh saying that there's so much
more evidence against Biden there was
against Kavanagh but not just if put
cabin all to the side for a minute there
is more evidence against Biden than
there was against a lot of the guys who
got caught up in the me2 movement many
of whom I'm sure we're actually guilty
but there's much more evidence against
him and there was against Allah with so
many of these cases in the me2 movement
all you really had was women making
accusations there was there was no other
evidence besides that with this you've
got Pete you have corroborating evidence
your people coming out and saying yes I
you told me about this I know about this
you've got video evidence from the Larry
King show I mean so there is if this is
not enough to convince you and I'm not
even saying it's enough to convince me
I'm not convinced
I think it's compelling evidence i I
think I certainly lean towards believing
and in fact I'll tell you one of the
remain reasons I lean towards believing
it on top of all the evidence in along
with the lack of an apparent political
motive of Tara Reid and she's not some
kind of conservative activist if she was
then I would say that's that's very
that's a very good reason to be
extremely skeptical but I'd say one of
the main reasons I lean towards
believing it is that Joe Biden has not
addressed it
okay and yeah he hasn't been forced to
address it because our clown car hack
media has has not forced the issue so he
hasn't he hasn't had to address it but
it's not as though this is some fringe
wacko on a blog somewhere making a claim
and I could see if you're a public
figure and there's a fringe wacko on a
blog making a claim and if it's not true
you might just ignore it and say nothing
about it unless you're forced to
acknowledge it that's not what's
happening here
yeah the mainstream media is ignoring it
but the story is still out there people
know about it so this is not a fringe
thing and yet Biden hasn't addressed and
so I think to myself if you're an
innocent man and there's this claim out
there about you and it's totally untrue
and but it's out there and millions of
people have heard about it wouldn't you
be champing at the bit to get out and
deny it why wouldn't you deny it there's
no reason not to again if it's if it's
something not a lot of people have heard
about then that's a reason maybe to not
to not acknowledge it or deny it because
you want to but you don't want to call
more attention to it but everybody knows
about it now why wouldn't you guy I mean
I you would have if it was me running
for office and this was out there and it
was false you would have to tie me to my
chair to get me to not go out and be
denying this hither and yon I mean
because you're innocent right so the
fact that Biden is not out there denying
it and addressing it head on and saying
this is simply not true it didn't happen
is not true this woman is lying he's not
saying that so anyway those are all the
reasons to lean towards believing it all
of that is more compelling adds up to
more compelling evidence and then
existed against a lot of the me2 guys
and many of whom by the way denied it
all so I'm not saying that denying it
proves they didn't do it but they at
least denied it so you've got a denial
and in many cases no evidence and you're
gonna believe that but not this so all
of these every single person who was
chair
mean to movement and now is defending by
it and they're all a bunch of
contemptible disgusting snakes really
they really are they don't they don't
give a damn about women they couldn't
care less
rape victims they don't care about you
at all
it's a game to them it's a game number
two LifeSite News reports the president
of the German Bishops Conference Bishop
George Batson has stated that the court
virus pandemic is not God's punishment
contradicting numerous Catholic leaders
who have called Cova 19 a chastisement
according to the website of the Diocese
of Limburg Germany bat Singh said on
April 23rd that he cannot understand
well people who consider Cova 19 God's
punishment my God has not known such
thoughts since Jesus died for us that is
when God has made his decision for life
God does not punish you said now I agree
actually that this is not a punishment
from God it's a virus they happen it's
also hard for me to see God sending a
punishment that is specifically
inflicted on the sick and the weak and
the vulnerable so if you call it a
punishment what you're saying is that
God is punishing us by specifically
inflicting additional pain and suffering
on people who are already in pain and
suffering so I have a pretty significant
theological problem with that however
obviously the idea that God doesn't
punish is absurd and there's no way to
read the Bible and come away with that
conclusion you just can't do it
number three The Wall Street Journal
reports that due to the government
relief efforts
half of all workers in the US stand to
earn more from unemployment that they
did from their jobs and this is a
perfect illustration so they're earning
more from unemployment they did for my
jobs I've actually gotten a lot of
emails from people saying this that
they're at they're in kind of a
crossroads there they're in a dilemma
right now because they file for
unemployment they're getting paid more
than they would in the workforce and yet
there may be there's a job opportunity
opened up they're trying to decide
should I take the job and take a pay cut
so that that's an interesting dilemma
this is a perfect illustration of what I
said earlier that you can't trust
government you can't trust government
because of corruption and and drum in
power drunkenness but also because of
plain old incompetence
trying to save the economy by passing a
bill that incentivizes unemployment is
crazy and I know you might say well this
this at least solves the problem there's
not gonna be people going hungry and so
on we know people are still going hungry
because look at the look at the lines of
the food bank so here's the problem
you got so many people being unemployed
all at once
talk about a curve oK you've got it you
got a massive meal being unemployed all
at once many of them don't qualify for
unemployment many of them have not been
able to get through to file for it many
of them have been waiting for their file
for their it claim to go through so
you've got a ton of people who for
whatever reason haven't or can't file
for unemployment and they're out of luck
completely they're the ones in line at
the food bank and then you've got
another segment of people who are yes
are being taken care of but to the
extent that they have no incentive to
get back into the work place
so this is the worst of both worlds
there are still millions of people who
are not being taken care of and who are
going hungry and have to wait in line of
food banks and you've got other people
who know there they have an incentive to
be unemployed and so now employers are
screwed because there are employers out
there who need workers and our hiring
actually but they're having a harder
time finding people because of the
because we even said the fight is
incentivized unemployment so it's just
it's a it's an absolute mess the worst
of every possible world is what the is
that's the solution the government has
given us number four the CDC is now
recommending that you socially distance
from your pets as well because there's a
minuscule possibility that your pets
would get could get the virus and so you
have to socially distance from them and
I think that is just not possible at all
if you have a dog because dogs do not
respect personal space and this is why I
don't understand why people like dogs so
much I mean this is this is actually the
reason people do like dogs they say I
love I come home the dog is jumping up
on me he's so excited he's always so
excited to be around me
yeah do you really need that kind of
affirmation all the time do you need
every time you walk in the door
to be jumping for joy that you walked in
the house you need someone following you
around all the time begging for your
attention now if you're a parent you've
already got some people following you
around begging for Dutch do you need
another creature in the house doing that
I don't get it number five and the CDC
is now saying that the models tell us
that deaths will rise again because of
the economy reopening the models have
spoken this is what you're gonna see see
in the economy isn't really reopening
like I said but it's allegedly reopening
and so now we're gonna start hearing
about the models the models the models
have spoken the models are saying the
models have said go back to your house
listen to the models obey the models do
not defy the models go into your home
hide under your bed lock your bedroom
door hide under your bed until the
models say it is safe all right we're
gonna go to our daily cancelation it is
as I said a well deserved one but before
we do I really want to tell you about
this you-you-you think about the impact
of all this on small business owners
many you know this has been a huge
strain obviously on small businesses and
small businesses are this is not some
political platitude small businesses are
the lifeblood of our economy most of the
businesses in America are small
businesses and the other thing is many
the even small businesses that are
managing to survive they're having to
deal with you know having staff work
remote and having to kind of adjust on
the fly now when you start having your
employees working remote you have to
manage your workforce and your workflow
really well you know systems are very
crucial the Benham brothers are great at
managing work teams that are all over
the country these guys have over a dozen
businesses including a real estate
empire that spans over 35 states the
name might ring a bell the Menem
brothers you might remember they were
slated for a reality TV show on HGTV
they were cancelled because of their
conservative values and they stuck with
those values even even giving up the TV
show all the money I'm sure that would
have come with that so a lot of respect
for these guys over the last six months
these guys have been work
on a new course called expert ownership
how to own a business without it owning
you it and in this course they teach
entrepreneurs and small business owners
the exact system they've used to build
better businesses if you're sitting at
home trying to run your business right
now expert ownership was made for you
the Benham brothers slash the cost of
the course to help small business owners
and entrepreneurs who are trying to
navigate all that's happening right now
so head over to Benham brothers comm
slash walsh to see a preview of the
course and get a special discount that's
been on brothers comm slash walls
benh a.m. brothers dot-com / walsh all
right actually we'll do the daily
cancellation in a second I also wanted
to play this for you just because it's
funny and I have to put it in somewhere
so we'll do here tick tock is generally
a god-forsaken hellscape of stupidity
and degeneracy but every once in a while
there is real art on tick tock there is
something really meaningful and valuable
and this is one of those times watch
this I never would have thought that the
girl that I decided to sit next to that
very first day in mr. Cooley seventh
grade science class would become one of
my best friends we have been through
everything together from all of our
annual Friday night sleepovers to the
many weekends spent away at dance
competitions to the many many margaritas
drank at the dirty dip in college
Daniel is perfect he's everything I
could ever imagine for you and more he's
tall he's handsome he has a pulse and
he's a boy the love you share for each
other inspires me each and every passing
day as I stand here today as your best
friend and maid of honor I can't help
but think back to that little girl and
mr. Cooley seventh grade side says who
always dreamed of the day she would bury
her prince charming well babe that day
is today so if everybody could please
join me in raising a toast to the new
mr. and mrs. Kaczynski and wish them
their happily ever after
thank you he nailed it Danny that's it
gets incredible the cadence the shaking
papers the banal personal details nobody
cares about everything the only thing he
missed because it's tick tock so time
constraints but really in real life the
speech goes on for 27 minutes contains
many more personal references in
anecdote
- memories and events that is of that
are of no interest to anybody in the in
the room that's why when people ask me
for public speaking tips because I do a
fair amount of public speaking and well
I used to anyway before all this and I
always say my first tip and this is in
general somebody asks for tips on
anything this is my first tip don't be
bad at it that's the most valuable
advice I can give first thing don't suck
okay
and the second is this if you are bad at
it be as short as possible that's
another thing that applies to everything
in life whatever you're doing don't be
bad at it if you are bad of it bad at it
do it do it do as a little of it as you
can which of course means you'll never
get better at it so maybe this isn't the
best advice but at least for the sake of
everybody else in the room we would
prefer if you we would prefer that
you're not bad at it if you are then
just be very short do not inflict
yourself on your audience for very long
and don't try to be funny because you're
not and remember when you get up there
to speak that you are being judged and
judged harshly by everybody in the room
however nervous you are you should be 10
times more nervous we are judging you
if it's terrible we will talk about you
behind your back we will remember how
bad this was the next time we see you
we'll think about how terrible you were
and we will have lost respect for you
okay keep that in mind as you go up
there it's very important that's my
public speaking advice and that's
probably why I've never been hired as a
public speaking coach or any other kind
of coach in fact now for your daily
cancellation this one you probably saw
coming from a mile away Mayor Bill
DeBlasio his canceled Mayor Bill thing
you have to realize about Mayor Bill is
that first of all he's an incompetent
doofus second he's actually evil okay so
he's an evil incompetent doofus and he
looks like a cartoon character other
than that he's a great guy I mean other
than those things I think he's a he's a
really splendid individual
so let's just review the last few months
in the world of mayor bill two months
ago bill was on TV
encouraging New Yorkers to go to go hit
the town go to the movies etc in fact he
initially responded to the corona virus
pandemic by giving movie recommendations
and saying hey folks go check out this
movie in the theaters that was his first
response to the to the epidemic not
making that up that's what he did then a
month later he completely reversed
himself with no acknowledgement that he
had reversed himself no apology for
putting New Yorkers in harm's way by
encouraging them to go out in the middle
of this and next thing you know he's
shutting everything now threatening to
close churches permanently if they don't
comply which of course is wildly
unconstitutional and he doesn't have
even the width of the authority to do
that
and then yesterday he sent out this
tweet look at the sweet here says my
message to the Jewish community and all
communities is this simple the time for
warnings has passed I have instructed
the NYPD to proceed immediately to
summons or even arrest those who gather
in large groups this is about stopping
the disease and saving lives period now
some people have tried to defend a bill
I won't even call Mayor Bill he's just
bill actually Billy some people have
tried to defend Billy by saying this is
out of context it's actually part of a
whole threat of tweets okay so you got
to put it in context that the defense is
that there is some context that would
make it okay for for Billy to tweet that
he's gonna round up the Jews and okay
let's look at the context okay let's
look at the entire tweet thread he says
something absolutely unacceptable
happened in Williamsburg tonight a
misspelling tonight a large funeral
gathering in the middle of this pandemic
when I heard I went there myself to
ensure the crowd was dispersed and what
I what I saw will not be tolerated so
long as we were fighting the coronavirus
then he goes on to message to the Jewish
community so on then he says we have
lost so many of these of these we've
lost so many these last two months and I
understand the instinct to gather to
mourn but large gatherings will only
lead to more deaths and more family
in mourning we will not allow it I have
instructed the NYPD to have one standard
for this whole city zero tolerance
yeah that doesn't make it any better
does it hey Mia doesn't make it any
better whatsoever this is one of those
things that context can't save you from
I want you to imagine this statement but
take out Jewish and put in say black my
message to the black community and all
communities is this simple the time for
warnings has passed or put in Muslim or
gay or really any other type of
community because another defense is
that he was actually talking to all
communities and even said and all
communities okay if you think that's
fine then then you should be okay with
take Jewish out put in any other type of
community then read it and tell me if
you'd be okay with that now you could
put in Christian there too I think he de
Blasio would have no problem threatening
Christians that way in fact he already
has he threatened to shut down churches
permanently so but it's a Jewish or
Christian I think he's fine threatening
but any other group including other
religious groups like I said Muslim do
you think he would can you ever imagine
Bill DeBlasio my message to the Muslim
community the time for warnings has
passed it would never happen ever so
this is just I mean how do you even
describe it it's despicable and I have
no respect for this guy whatsoever well
I won't refer to him as his title he
does not deserve it hasn't earned it he
doesn't respect the law that's supposed
to govern him which is the Constitution
and so I have no respect for him
whatsoever
he has no moral authority at all in his
position and he should be ignored my
mess
to the religious community in New York
is to ignore this son of a you know what
this is not acceptable we could joke
about it and make light of it but but
starting with him threatening to close
down houses of worship permanently this
is dictatorial tyrannical nonsense and
it is not acceptable this is not just
some silly little thing oh that's
DeBlasio being de Blasio again no this
is him being a tyrant and operating
illegally he has no legal right
whatsoever to make a threat like that
and to be singling out Jews in the
middle of a crisis okay we we have seen
historically Jews being blamed in a
crisis before we know how that goes so
to call this reckless and irresponsible
would be to only scratch the surface of
what we're dealing with here so de
Blasio was cancelled at a minimum let's
move let's move on to your emails and
you can always email the show at if you
become a daily Y remember you can email
the mailbag this is let's go right to
our E or Erie says hi Matt love the show
my least favorite cliche is live in the
moment can you talk about why that's
actually terrible advice I figure you'd
have a good way of putting it I like I
like these I like these kinds of emails
I get these emails a lot where people
assign me an opinion and say well I know
your opinion is this let's hear you
defended and I can see why you think
that that would be my opinion that I
would think that live in a moment is a
stupid cliche I mean it is a cliche yes
but I'm not convinced that it's a
terrible that it that is actually
terrible advice
it's it's terrible advice only in a
sense that all cliches are terrible
advice in that there's no point in even
offering them as advice because the
receiver of the advice has heard it a
million times already and will just tune
it out so even if it's true there are a
lot of cliches that are true but
no point in saying them because it you
might as well just be singing the ABC
song or something it's just it's just
words at this point we've all heard it
so many times it doesn't doesn't have
any impact it's like telling somebody
look on the bright side I mean there's
there's even if they should be looking
on the bright side there's no point in
saying that because no one's gonna hear
that and say wow you know I never
thought of that I never heard that
before
never thought it I think I will look on
the bright side this has changed my life
thank you for that insight that's never
gonna happen
but even so live in the moment I think
we should find another way of phrasing
it so it's not a cliche anymore but it
does contain an important truth I think
even the gospel tells us Jesus and the
Sermon on the Mount
says talks about the birds of the air
lilies of the field how they aren't
stressing over tomorrow and sufficient
for the day is its own evil and so on
there's there's a deep truth there even
if it's been reduced to a to a mundane
maudlin platitude
there is a truth to it the truth of and
I think the truth of live in a moment is
this that when someone says live in the
moment what they really mean is live in
reality okay face reality face the truth
of your circumstance and operate
accordingly I think I think that's what
live in the moment really means because
of course in reality you have no choice
but to live in the moment you have to
you can't live anywhere else
the past is gone the past is now just a
thought a memory the future is a hope an
assumption maybe a fear and anxiety but
it's not a real hard reality and when it
does become a real reality it's not the
future anymore it's it's it's it's this
present moment so that's all you ever
really have so maybe live in the moment
is more of a reminder than advice it's
more of a way of saying hey you know you
are at being stuck in time and space all
you can ever do is take each moment as
it comes you literally have no other
choice
so you might as well face that and stop
being delusional and and lived that way
I was actually thinking about this
recently because you know I said that
the past is just a memory but in truth
the past isn't even isn't even that in
most cases I was thinking about and
feeling disturbed
the fact that I have forgotten almost
everything that has ever happened to me
almost everything I've ever thought fell
said experienced almost all of it I have
forgotten it it's gone
in fact I forget almost everything
happens to me as soon as it happens and
that's not just me that's that's true of
all of us think about it think about how
many moments you have lived millions of
moments how many of them can you recall
vividly probably not that many and I
don't know how they tallied this but I
was reading recently that the average
person has 70,000 thoughts in a day I
have no idea I think opossum and
quantify how many thoughts a person has
in a day but let's just say for the sake
of argument that at 70,000 how many of
your 70,000 from yesterday can you
remember now or a week ago or a year ago
right so many of those thoughts are gone
and you're never gonna have them back so
I mean I'm sure we've all had
experiences of looking at old pictures
and having it bring to mind an event in
our lives that we'd all that you
basically forgotten about even though it
was meaningful at the time enough that
you took a picture of it and then you
look at it and you kind of remember oh
yeah I remember that happening and but
this was that this really meaningful
thing that happened to you that it
already slipped all the way to the
peripherals of your mind and and and you
had all but lost any memory of it so all
that is just to say that I mean even the
past when you think about it it's it's
good really is gone I mean in almost
every sense not even a memory so much of
what you experience and think not only
will you forget it but everyone will
forget it and what does that mean it
just means that well it just goes back
to that that all you have is now is now
you have this moment so you might as
well do something with it what other
choice do you have
and at the end of your life when you're
looking back and if you're feeling
regrets it's just it's a regret over
moments that were wasted not just
moments wasted like doing stuff that you
not doing something you wanted to do or
doing stuff that you shouldn't been
doing I mean you'll have those kind of
regrets too but a lot of your regrets
are just gonna be about your priorities
about the things that you chose to think
about about the things you chose you
know those 70,000 thoughts you had each
day you're gonna regret a lot of those
thoughts just you chose to think about
and care about the wrong things and so
on so I think the polat's the point of
that cliche and there is a lot of a lot
of truth to it
not that I'm at all good and actually
living in the moment I have to say but
all right now that we've gotten that
cliche out of the way I think we'll
leave it there hope these these moments
were not wasted for you I'm afraid they
probably were there's probably better
things you could have been doing and
listening to me but hey you can't get it
back it's the past now so sorry
I'll talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson
the Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew clip
[Music]